unrest is growing in China over strict
covid-19 lockdown measures protests have
broken out in several parts of the
country including in the xinjiang region
where many people have bombarded for
leaving their homes for more than three
months protests in the regional Capital
urmchi came after an apartment block
fire killed 10 people some residents say
the restrictions on movement hampered
rescue efforts
growing frustration over the lockdowns
almost three years after the pandemic
broke out is increasingly putting
beijing's zero covet policy under
pressure
journalist Fabian kretchma is in Beijing
under lockdown's restrictions here
Michelle Fabian good to see you tell us
about the conditions you're dealing with
right now
yeah this afternoon local time my
building got locked down why because one
neighbor tested positive during the
daily mass test that we are facing
already for many months now and to give
you an idea I mean my building has 25
floors so one person is positive that
means we all have to stay inside the
building and lockdown that's that means
that we are physically prevented from
leaving if I go downstairs then um at
the building entrance there will be a
half a dozen people members of the local
neighborhood committee and also health
workers in full hazmat suits and yeah
they they build up a fence if I want to
you know cross that line they will get
very unfriendly so you're literally
locked in your own home and that's the
Fate that many beijingers or I mean
several hundred millions of Chinese in
the country are facing right now so I'm
not the only one right and this of
course is uh is happening uh always very
sudden and you can only hope that your
fridge is fully uh filled with
everything that you need I mean any word
on how long this might last
I mean this really unpredictability
that's exactly what makes us so mentally
unnerving you don't know how long it
will last um the the neighborhood
committee who runs our residential
compound also doesn't know they won't
give you any answer so it could be five
days but who knows if they discover
another case could be another five days
this could go on and on and uh really
even if we um are free um and you know
everything is fine in one week then you
know it's only a matter of time until we
get locked down again I mean it's enough
if only one um person in the whole
building tests positive again so really
you have a very deep sense of
unpredictability you cannot plan for the
next week and uh for me I mean I'm
rather privileged but I mean all the
migrant workers if they get locked down
then um they don't have much savings so
they're really um are under an
existential economic threat here right
and no wonder then there's restrictions
uh like those you're describing they've
been very frustrating for many people in
China do tell us more about the events
in Orem she
yeah that was really a very tragic
incident
um on Thursday night a fire broke out
there wasn't a high-rise residential
building on the 15th floor and um yeah
the claims are that you know those 10
deaths could have been prevented if
there was not a you know excessive
lockdown because the rescue workers they
needed a very long time to get to the
building um because of all the fences
the restrictions of movement then also
the um people in the compound they could
not leave so easily because there were
locks the apparently the fire exit also
is supposed to have been locked and I
mean that's very credible I've seen that
in also quarantine facilities here that
you know the exit um are really with an
iron locked closed so I mean that's very
tragic and it's not the first time that
people are dying because of the tragic
side effects of those lockdowns it's
really sparked a lot of anger and people
in uromusi are they've gone to the
streets they've protested and they do
that under very very great risk and
under great Danger but still they are so
fed up they have nothing to lose they
went on to the streets and actually it
helped the next day the the local
government said okay we're basically
clearing up now and um relaxing some of
the restrictions uh and is this
something that can be sustainable the
relaxation I mean how big of a challenge
are these protests uh we're witnessing
in China to the country's irokovic
policy
yeah the frustration is as high as it
has never been before during the
pandemic if you go on social media you
see a lot of Chinese posting very
critical
um statements very critical videos and
also those who are actually not so
political or who are not so or were
rather patriotic but even they've had
enough and um the sensors are really at
uh at working overtime you scroll
through a social media opening links and
the next morning everything is deleted
so it's it's really shows you something
and usually I would say that you know
this anger on social media could also
disappear soon it has happened before
but um nowadays I mean it's hard to see
a light at the end of the tunnel because
even despite those really strong
lockdowns the cases are rising um uh
Beijing is posting record high numbers
the country is also posting record high
numbers also the the already the fourth
consecutive day so um I mean the the
restrictions will go on if the
government doesn't change its course but
right now they're really doubling down
on zero covet so um I don't see any
solution for that there's really a lot
of frustration here all right uh
journalist Fabian they are reporting for
us from Beijing himself in lockdown as
well Fabian thank you so much